un bâtiment flambant neuf encore vides
mais qui accueillera bientôt les élèves
de classes préparatoires du lycée
militaire de saint cyr l'école c'est
pour l'inaugurer que la ministre
déléguée auprès de la ministre des
armées geneviève darrieussecq a fait le
déplacement ce jeudi en suivre lier ce
projet de bâtiment pol lapeyre tout
simplement le démarrage de grands
chamboulements ici à saint cyr l'école
un chamboulement positif bien sûr avec
une amélioration des conditions
d'accueil des lycéens et des étudiants
et ce premier bâtiment année le
témoignage puisqu'il va abriter
c'est un bâtiment d'hébergement pour les
étudiants en classes préparatoires
d'autres changements sont prévus dans
l'établissement un autre bâtiment va
être rénové d'ici 2022
il accueillera alors l'internât et celui
inauguré aujourd'hui deviendra en
bâtiment d'enseignement
ces travaux ont lieu dans le cadre du
plan l'iss et mis en place par la
ministre
j'ai mis en oeuvre un plan lycée avec un
plan d'investissements ambitieux dans
les établissements parce qu'il y avait
des certains établissements avec des
structures très vieillissante et qui
n'était plus aux normes du 21e siècle et
donc ce plan lycée a été décidée fin
les premiers plans ont été élaborés en
et là nous avons déjà la réalisation ici
à saint cyr l'école
le but que les élèves soit accueilli
dans de meilleures conditions
à la fin de cette visite rey la ministre
a tenu un comité directeur du plan lycée
pour suivre l'évolution des
investissements dans les établissements
concernés